Film Courage: At what moment did you say “I’m
really going to do this!”
Because we all love to think of these awesome
ideas and then they last what, maybe a day,
a week, whatever?
That is essentially what the book (NFA) is
about, actually doing something, not just
talking about it.
Jeff Leisawitz: [Laughs] Right…One of my
favorite quotes is “Between concept and
execution, there is a land of shadow!”
Film Courage: [Laughs] That’s good!
Jeff Leisawitz: There is another one I love
which is “When all is said and done, there
is generally a lot more said than done.”
Film Courage: Very true…and maybe…different
in the Seattle area than it is in Los Angeles
but…LA can be known for this.
Jeff Leisawitz: So when did I really gear
into this?
I think it was sort of in that moment or time
period when I realized that this was really
coming from a deep place within me.
That both the creative side and the empowerment
and inspirational side.
These things came together in the book.
And the book is one thing and we’re getting
that out and whatever (people are digging
it) but I’m also doing lots of workshops.
And this for me is actually more powerful
because, you know, I already wrote the book.
Hopefully people will read it and that’s
great.
But interacting with groups of people, whether
online or in live situations really gives
me a chance to connect and obviously there
is a bit more to it than reading a book, like
there are humans involved.
Film Courage: The book (NFA) has a lot of
humor in it and I enjoyed the drawings as
well.
You have one illustration that is fairly close
to the beginning of the book where there is
a guy sitting on his couch watching television,
kind of slumped down and depressed with maybe
a beer on the table next to him.
I find it interesting because this is the
acceptable form of recreation and we’ve
all probably fallen prey to it (it’s easy
to go there).
Why do you think so many people reach for…not
just a beer or whatever (we don’t have to
talk about addiction or anything) but that
safe place on the couch?
Why is this so commonplace?
Jeff Leisawitz: Because it’s easy.
[Laughs] Right?
I mean it’s easy to lay there, drink a beer
and click around or eat your ice cream or
whatever you’re into.
It takes energy to do anything.
Whether you are going to write your book or
make your film or write a song or any of those
creative things take energy.
But here’s the difference, at the end of
the day when you’re done watching your TV
show…okay…fine.
Maybe it was good, maybe it s*cked?
That’s the end of it.
When you create something, that energy comes
back to you.
It doesn’t come back to you with the TV
show, generally.
Film Courage: That’s a good point.
Jeff Leisawitz: So the more energy you put
in, the more energy you have, if it’s something
that you genuinely, absolutely love.
Film Courage: Now you talk about this in the
book and forgive me if I’m getting too personal
with it…but you said during the time when
you were going to attend high school or leaving
high school to attend college, that you had
a lot of people around you that you were close
to pass away?
Jeff Leisawitz: Yes.
Film Courage: Was this part of that NFA mindset
that you adopted because you witnessed that
people probably had best intentions and plans.
Jeff Leisawitz: It was definitely a very tough
time for me coming out of high school and
you know “the world is in front of us”
kind of thing and suddenly seeing “Wow.
This thing can end and has for several of
my friends.”
It was a huge shock and a deep introspection
to just know that time is always ticking.
We don’t know if we’re going to get another
50 years or 10 minutes, but there is always
a limit to this life, as far as we know.
So what are you going to do with it?
And for me (you’re right) after I got out
of that funk it was like “Okay, let’s
do something meaningful with life.
It’s a gift.”
Film Courage: Do you remember what got you
out of that funk?
Jeff Leisawitz: It might have been meeting
the greatest guitar player I’ve ever played
with, a guy called Mike Schmidt in college.
I met this guy…lot of people play guitar
and I played music with people back then.
But Mike was an extraordinary musician, like
ultra level.
And for some reason he wanted to play with
me in a band.
He taught me a whole lot.
Not just about music but about life through
music.
So the story that I remember that was really
so huge for me was at that time I would learn
a song and play it (do a cover song or write
a song).
I went to get together with Mike and I’m
like “Mike, what song do you want to play?”
And he’s like “I don’t want to play
a song.”
And I’m like “What do you want to do?”
and he’s like “Just play.
Just play.”
And I start playing the bass and Mike starts
carving music out of out of my semi-chaotic,
erratic bass line and it was beautiful!
And what I got out of that was how music was
completely open and free, which is similar
to life, right?
The more structured you are, there is great
stuff in that.
But if you can be free and loose with your
plan, magic can happen.
It’s like a Grateful Dead song.
You ever listen to the Dead?
Film Courage: Well I grew up in a town that
worshipped the Grateful Dead.
I grew up in Palo Also, so yeah, every year
there was a huge Dead concert/festival essentially.
[Laughs]
Jeff Leisawitz: Right…so the Dead sort of
jam every night (or used to) and some nights
it was just a disaster!
It was a sonic mess that you just never would
think…what the hell?
Then…other nights it was music that was
just so heavenly and divine.
Like how can humans make something so beautiful?
They have to step into that chaos.
They have to step into the possibility and
just see how it goes.
That’s kind of what I got from Mike back
then.